I think it's always good to be a
grown-up ideals which is the whole
subtitle of the book is grown-up
idealist a grown-up idealist is someone
who recognizes the equal importance of
things as they are and things as they
should be this is a distinction that
goes back in particular in all its
clarity to immanuel kant I think the big
metaphysical problem i'm not sure that
and i'm loath to talk about one big
problem but the central problem
connecting both metaphysics and morality
is the difference between things as they
are and things as they should be and
most people tend to err on one side or
the other most people tend either to
look at things as they should be and
talk themselves into the idea that
things really perhaps are as they should
be without looking at the facts on the
ground you can also air in the other
direction and use the word realistic to
mean just taking things as they happen
to be right now think about what you
mean when you tell somebody to be
realistic what you're really saying is
decrease your expectations you know
things aren't things aren't going to get
much better they'll probably get worse
and you got all your psychological bases
covered if you assume actually the worst
so that's a form of realism that says
well the way that things are now is the
only thing that's real is it's the only
thing we should pay attention to a
grown-up idealist pays attention to both
he says I absolutely can look at things
as they are in the face while still
guiding my actions by ideals of things
as they should be
you